- And this guy stands up
right in the middle,
right in the middle
of the entire audience,
and stands up and has
this "Braveheart" moment.
And he goes,
"He doesn't speak Spanish!"
[growling]
[dark electronic music]
♪♪
[cheers and applause]
- All right, this next guy
is a good friend of mine.
I've known him
for about 10, 12 years.
He's absolutely hilarious.
He's on "The Daily Show"
as the Latino correspondent.
Please give it up
for Mr. Al Madrigal, everybody!
Let him hear it!
[cheers and applause]
- So, in 2002, I went
to the Montreal Just for Laughs
Comedy Festival,
which is like the NBA Draft
for young comedians.
There's a new face.
And I was so excited to see
the one other Latino comedian
that was there--
his name is Willie Barcena.
He's a great comic.
Yeah, I was so excited.
I go, "Hey, Willie!
How you doing?
Al Madrigal.
How are you?"
And he just walked up,
and he goes,
"You don't even say
your own name right, bro?"
And just--
[laughter]
And just walked away.
And...
as he left, I go, "Oh, yeah,
okay, Willie, see you later."
And I had no idea
I was even--
I hadn't gone to L.A.
at that point.
I was up in San Francisco.
I had no idea that I was
a Mexican comedian.
I had no clue.
That's how bad--
My Spanish is horrible.
And I go down to L.A.
for the very first time,
and I didn't know that L.A.--
You do this now
with all these shows,
and none of these are made up,
but they take
all the black comics,
and they have Chocolate Sundaes
at the Laugh Factory
and Mo Better Mondays
and Chopshtick Wednesdays,
if you're an Asian comic, and--
and they go--
All my Persian friends
are on the Axis of Evil show
and so on and so on.
So I go down there
with my friend Becky.
This is my first set
in L.A.
And that's your first sign
right there.
No self-respecting
Mexican comedian
has a friend
named Becky, right?
You're never gonna hear,
"Me and my friend Becky
got some pressed juices."
Uh, yeah...
That's not...
So, anyway, we go down,
and she has a set
at the historic Melrose Improv,
with the Budd Friedman
and the monocle.
And it's for the HBO
Aspen Comedy Arts Festival,
another big deal
for young comedians.
And so I watch her check in,
and she gets
an HBO Comedy hat,
HBO Comedy T-shirt,
and she checks in for her show.
She's on the Thursday night
8:30 show
with the rest of my friends.
And then I go to check in,
and they give me a tin
of Red Hots,
like a Hot Tamales candies,
in a mini Altoids case
that says "HBO Latino."
[laughter]
And I get that,
and then I go and check in
for my show,
and I'm on the Friday night
late show
called "Refried Fridays."
And it's with Carlos Mencia,
Gabriel Iglesias,
hosted by Pablo Francisco,
Jeff Garcia,
Freddy Soto,
God rest his soul.
And so I look at the Red Hots.
I look at the list
one more time,
and I look at Becky,
and I call her.
[whispering]
I go, "Becky.
"I'm a Mexican comedian.
What do I do?"
[normal voice]
And right at that moment,
this guy taps me
on the shoulder and goes,
"Hola.My name is Mateo.
I'm from HBO Latino.
Do you mind if I interview you
in Spanish?"
And I go,
"You can fucking try, bro.
"It's not--it's not
gonna work out for you.
And, by the way,¿cómo se dice,■
'Where's my T-shirt?'
"How do you say that?
"Because everyone else
got T-shirts,
and I got these Red Hots."
[laughter]
And then the gigs
started coming in.
You know, I have a young family
in Los Angeles,
and I get these, uh--
At first, when you start doing
comedy in San Francisco,
you do open mics, right?
There's no microphone there.
It's like three homeless people
passed out
at this place called
The Luggage Store that I did.
Then you find out there was
a microphone in Oakland.
So we went over
to Jack London Square
and performed in front of all,
like, these black gang members.
So I was like just doing
my stuff and somebody goes,
"That's not funny,
motherfucker."
And I go, "It's new stuff.
I'm working on it, RJ."
And he's just talking.
"Just trying
premises out, so..."
But then this really big gig--
once I moved down to L.A.
And it's funny that it brought
me back to the Bay Area,
but I get this gig
in East San Jose, California.
You don't have to be familiar
with the San Francisco Bay Area
to know than anything east,
most cities,
usually pretty shitty.
So...
driving there with my wife,
commercial comes
on the oldies station,
Tony Sandoval,
KISS FM,
for the show
I'm actually going to do.
So, "We got a big Latino
comedy jam,
and Al Madrigal
is going to be there!"
I'm in my car going, "Whoa.
Oh, so that's how you say it.
Okay, got it."
Then I go to the gig,
and it's 2,000 Mexicans
in a GI hall...
just packed.
It's like a big cafeteria.
And my wife looks at me,
and she goes,
"Dude, you got to get
the fuck out of here!"
'Cause she's supportive
like that.
And I say, "No, honey.
Have a little faith in me.
I can handle myself."
is that the guy before me is
doing his entire act in Spanish
and destroying.
Every single time
he hits a big punch line,
little Mexican guys
with gold-plated teeth--
they all have corn
on a stick,
so they're fucking putting
their corns in the air.
Crema is flying everywhere.
It's like "Cloudy
with a Chance of Carnitas."
[laughter]
And I didn't know
that the Mexican corn
was like the concert lighter
for a Latino Def Jam Show.
[shouting]
So now I got to go up there.
And I ask myself--
I go, "Okay, I can do this.
What would Carlos Mencia do
in this situation?"
That's one of the rare times
you want to ask
yourself that question.
And I go, "I know.
I'm gonna go up there."
And I do a little cheerleading.
So I go up onstage, and I go,
"What's up, East San Jose?
Make some noise!"
And they all
make some noise.
All right,
so I'm doing good.
So I say, "Where are
all the white people at?
White people make some noise.
White people!"
Nothing.
Half of me is
the only white guy there.
So I say, "Where are
all the black people at?
Black people make some noise!
Black people!"
Nothing.
Where the hell were you guys?
Could've fucking used you!
And then I say,
"So it's all Latinos!"
[imitates cheering]
2,000 corns just up in the air
at the exact same time.
And I'll never forget, right
where you are in the front,
this little guy goes,
"East side Latinos."
And I said, "East side Latinos!"
Even bigger roar.
Like, I think a bacon-wrapped
hot dog went flying.
Then I proceeded
to do my act
just by saying
"fuckers" and "bros" nonstop.
Just "fuckers" and "bro,"
"fuckers" and "bros,"
and then humping
for no reason whatsoever.
It didn't make
any fucking sense.
If you're sitting
near a Latino,
look how much
they love this right now.
They can't get enough.
Does not make sense,
but they can't get enough of it.
What's up, fuckers?
I just had a new baby,
fuckers.
Fuckers, bro, bro,
fuckers, fuckers.
25,000 "fuckers" later,
25 minutes,
I'm out of there.
Then I go to the next gig.
It's a two-parter.
Next day it's
in Stockton, California,
which is this meth shithole
in the middle of nowhere.
Industry has died.
It was like Ground Zero
for the housing crisis, right?
Foreclosure signs everywhere.
People are angry
all the time.
I think there's just pods
with embryonic MMA fighters.
And when you start to do
stand-up, the younger comics--
The older comics
pull us to the side,
and they tell us three shows
that you should not do.
I was just told this
by great comics
that sort of were very helpful.
They said,
"Don't perform outside.
"Don't perform
in front of kids.
And don't perform
during the day."
This is all three.
Even the kids
are fucking tough in Stockton.
I'm not sure if anyone's
ever been intimidated
by a five-year-old, but--
little wife-beaters
walking by,
going, "Fuck you,ese."
And you're like, "Ah.
Okay, children, run along."
So I walk into the show,
and I walk backstage.
The guy who was doing so well
the night before--
Remember him?
He's now crying.
He's got a tear
running down his cheek.
And I go, "Ruben, what's wrong?
How was your set?"
He goes,
"Al, they threatened my life."
What happened was,
he went up in Stockton,
and he went onstage
and said he was from L.A.
And apparently
Ruben hadn't been watching
his National Geographic
gang documentaries,
because that was a no-no.
Big battle going on
between the north and the south.
Ruben was unaware.
He went up,
said he was from Los Angeles,
and guys started sharpening
their corn sticks.
They were ready
to fucking stab his ass.
He pointed the dudes out.
Now I got to go up there,
and I already determined
on the long car ride out,
"I'm not gonna be
this Latino Def Jam character
that I'm not."
I spent the first half
of my life--
My parents sent me
to French school
in San Francisco.
I went to
Ecole Notre Dame Des Victoires.
All right?
I used to wear a sailor suit
to school every single day.
I rode the cable car with
a dickey blowing in the wind.
Now I'm gonna be
this Latino Def Jam character?
That's bullshit.
I want to be myself.
And that was a horrible idea.
Never be yourself.
Change it up. Fuck it.
What do you got to lose?
So I go up onstage,
and I start to do this bit
about how my Spanish is horrible
and how you spot half Mexican--
overuse of the word"poquito."
¿Habla español?
Un poquito.
¿Salsa picante?
¿Maricón?
Un poquito.
And this guy stands up
right in the middle,
right in the middle
of the entire audience,
and stands up and has
this "Braveheart" moment.
And he goes,
"He doesn't speak Spanish!"
[growling]
And then starts
violently flipping me off.
Not just like,
"Hey, fuck you."
But the holding it, shaking,
going...
[groaning]
So he starts leading people
in boos against me.
He's going,
"He doesn't speak Spanish.
"Boo! Boo!
Boo! Boo!"
20 people are booing,
80 people are booing,
and finally I broke down,
which I tend to do.
I said, "Look, you guys,
"this isn't exactly
a dream gig for me either.
"I'm stuck in Stockton
of all God forsaken places,
"and the best part about it
is I get to leave,
"and you people are stuck here
"for the rest of your
miserable fucking lives.
"Now, I'm taking the money,
and I'm being paid handsomely.
"I'm gonna go blow it
in Tracy Outlet Mall.
So fuck off!"
And the guy stood
back up and goes,
"He's got money!"
Then I ended up jumping a fence
like a salmon,
while the black security guards
laughed at me.
That's how that
fucking turned out.
All right, thank you
very much, everybody.